oops possible this week's guests are not
too deep is my good friend Jarrett
sleeper he was in the fine brother
scripted series my music with me he
played metal with the crazy hair and
he's just been a really great friend
that I feel like I've lived a thousand
lifetimes with and has become quickly
one of my favorite guests I'm not too
deep we had a really wonderful
conversation and this segment that
you're about to see is maybe one of my
favorite moments from all of not too
deep history jarrett was tasked with
answering the silly and somewhat simple
question what would you do if you woke
up as a woman
for the day check out this answer we're
here it's Jarrett's sleeper today how
would you describe yourself I see you're
a Renaissance man of entertainment keep
that coming well Jared and I met each
other on a original series created by
the fine brothers called my music that
show is super fun very life changing
thing for me was think about it yeah
because like right yeah I was like I
don't know it I thought YouTube was only
cat videos right now I understand it's
only 90% I was just like you know bang
around I do like shows I was in theater
I do stuff here and there I was a
butcher I was like own shop they were
all as being right Emilie's bros and
yeah and I'm a family that combined like
six months later making that first I
made like a viral video yeah oh the gym
what do you think is the best place for
someone to find a mysterious piece of
ham like finding $20 in your pocket like
right out of the dryer so it's more
making a very high-quality him I'm
thinking like a Virginia ham or a nice
prosciutto you know I'm assuming a slice
cuz my viewer my first thing I thought
was inside the CD tray of your iMac CD
tray dude you just aged yourself are you
born before the 90s when you signed on
mine does it sound like you guys are
bullying
this is emotional violence if you
suddenly found yourself turning to a
woman how would you spend your day I
feel like it's it's weird to talk about
like gender stuff because there's so
much like propriety around it now about
talking about like and you know it's I
have no interest in making light of any
like it's not because I really believe
it I've been like I've I think masculine
and feminine is like a weird thing that
we are uncomfortable talking because
it's so politicized and we think it
means like man and woman sure but it's
like a yin yang thing those are like an
energy thing to energy thing in a big
way yeah and and I feel like the way I
emotionally process and experience life
and the kind of sensitivities I have in
the way I pay attention it's more
feminine it always just felt like I'm
like a lady right side like very much
like not even I just feel a woman but
also I have I think about this all the
time like there's yourself on the vessel
and I'm not you deep not to you but I
also have this male body and the male
body comes with all its own chemicals
and stuff like our undeniably masculine
yes and so it creates this great
identity strangeness and interaction of
the world and how you're received and
how you act it's actually something I'm
really curious about because I've been
talking a lot with people about the
masculine and feminine energies and a
lot of inter couple like relationship
issues come from the idea that one
person is supposed to have a masculine
energy and one person's list of a female
and when it's not necessarily balanced
that way when the other person that's
what's that female has more masculine
qualities there's like this underlying
tension growing up there's a lot of like
gender bias stuff in our culture
traditionally masculine qualities this
is why feminism is an important thing is
because like it's feminism is about it
being okay for anybody to experience
feminine qualities and understand the
strengths in those yeah and I was not
like there's this complaint that
masculine qualities are our good ones
like saying like if you're a boy you're
like leadership like if you're bossy or
[ __ ] if you're a girl if you're bossing
your guy you're like a leader things
that met boys are rewarded for strength
aggression competitiveness hmm like
being smart or clever yeah like all that
stuff they the way our capitalist
society is set up is like that's what
you're rewarded for yeah and so it's
like a negative thing not to let women
have that experience either whereas
women are traditionally encouraged and
rewarded
for being pretty and gentle and soft and
engraved behind and carry all those
things but for me I was like I would
always get so upset when I was a kid I
didn't I didn't want it I longed for
someone to just say that I would think
consider me beautiful or appreciate a
sensitivity in me or something like that
more emotionally driven it just never
resonated like beating people yeah
cheetah beating this isn't getting great
scores yeah being like all that stuff
was I was like I would extrapolate it
out and be like that's what makes the
world shitty yeah like all that stuff
the rat race and beating and winning and
all this stuff that would power of that
kind and the stuff that was like Iowa's
since a child I was I was raised in
museums a little bit hard it was like
beauty beauty is like probably my
overarching virtue and and not like you
know beauty and the real sense of beauty
like beauty can be ugly and strange and
specific yeah bizarre but like you know
so let's say let's like a woman inside I
just play up my tears masturbate like
crazy long walk to that answer so make
sure that you listen to the full podcast
if you would like on soundcloud and
itunes and follow Jarrett across social
media platforms and I'll see you next
time
I don't know you can't get context of
how big they're when they're together
because they all look normally watching
basketball
I have no context for basketball like
they're all enormous like you forget
like I can never fail people no not at
all you know and they're all just like
no
[Music]